the market where the first case were
linked to the juanan wholesale seafood
market in wuhan
and and we also looked at
many studies that were conducted in the
past few months
in china on different animal species
trying to
find or have a better idea of whether
some
animal species would be
harboring this virus we looked at all
these
studies we received a lot of data raw
data
process data result of studies and
analysis done locally and we process
that
all that together with our chinese
counterparts we also look
at molecular and genetic data available
to help us link all the other pieces
together
we look at and analyze all the sequences
genetic sequences of the virus coming
from different sources in december 19
and january 2020 to try to
give us a better picture of what we we
could find
about the the start of this of this
event
in terms of uh key uh
data we looked at on the epidemiology
side we looked
among other things into
data coming out of different sovereign
systems
particular uh certain system looking at
cases of fever
cases of in unspecified pneumonia
ili and iris systems which are
respiratory
syndromes that are picked up by
different health facilities
so we look at more than 76 000
cases of these symptomatic
individuals in the months before
december to try to look if anything
there could look like covet cases that
had not been picked up before but
at the end of the day we didn't find
anything
but this is only a first set of studies
and among other things our
recommendation is to look back
in more detail into many of these data
sets we also look at the data
around the confirmed cases in december
2019
the 174 cases we know
were confirmed in at that time in
wohan and they are clearly during the
second half of
december we could see a surge of cases
both among the ones linked to the market
but increasingly as we move
uh towards the end of december
increasingly cases not linked with the
market
indicating that the disease was already
at that time spreading
uh outside uh in in the different part
of wuhan
um and and and uh
therefore the the more we move into the
second half of december
the less relevant the market itself uh
become because then the disease is
spreading
uh around we also look at data from
mortality statistics data to see could
we see any excess
mortality any sign of an excess
number of deaths in the period before
december 2019
in and around gohan and also elsewhere
in the province
and we could not uh there
see anything happening before december
uh
and and clearly looking at the this type
of data
we could see that the an upsurge of
mortality in the in the numbers of
of of this somehow
in january towards the start of january
2020 in wuhan compatible with the fact
that
the number of cases was growing
already at the end of december in the
city and we also could see that
outside wuhan this increase in mortality
came a little bit later
indicating again that the event at least
in in the province started in wuhan
and then moved more and more outside
outside wuhan
we also look of course at the market the
juan market we went there
and it's closed market now for for more
than a year
but it was still very interesting to see
the setting to see the state
of of the physical environment in which
these events
unfolded more than a year ago and
we also were able to map the entire
market to a huge market with more than
1500
vendors and shops and mapping all of
them with the different type of
products they were selling different
type of meats poultry
seafood wild animal meat etc
and could link that with both the
positive environmental samples that were
found
in different surveys in the market but
also with the human cases
uh in particular in the early days of
december
and by putting all these data together
together with the sequencing
data we could we could show that
the virus was circulating in the in the
market as
early as the beginning of december 19
2019 but there were also cases not
related to the market
outside the the market
of the juan market with slightly
different
differences in the in the genetic makeup
of the virus
these cases had showing that there was
probably some
circulation in different parts of the
city
unrelated to each other
and remember the cases we picked up in
december
2019 when only the severe cases at that
time
a kovitt case was a case of severe
pneumonia
all the mild cases were missed because
they were not at that time we didn't
know that there was
many mild cases or even asymptomatic
cases so all these
other cases were never picked up and of
course they could
help us get much better understanding of
the start of the
epidemic if we had access or could
detect these these
these cases we were also able for each
of the interesting vendors in the market
we were able to
trace back their suppliers in particular
the
shop selling uh farmed wild animals of
of much interest in our work we could
we could detect or identify the
suppliers
they were using all the way back to the
farms providing
and raising these animals in different
provinces of
of the country and in particular in some
provinces
where we know that bad population of
interest
are also there so clearly
pointing into interesting new studies to
be conducted in the in the coming months
so again this is only a first start
we've only scratched the surface of this
very complex
set of studies that need to be conducted
and we have pointed too many
additional studies that should be
conducted
from now on we were also able to
do a lot of analysis on the genetic
sequences
of the virus that were isolated in
december
and early january at the start of the
epidemic and being able to
to see how these sequences were linked
in evolution meaning
helping us to understand um
and and and try to understand where and
when
uh the the the start of the of the
presence of the virus could uh could be
related to
uh so and you will see that in the
report there is a lot of very
detailed information and useful
information that the gain
point towards the need for very specific
new studies chinese counterparts
ahead of our coming were also conducting
a large number of surveys and
animals different type of animals wild
animals animals from
zoos animals from farms domestic animals
etc
dozens of thousands of animals were
tested and all negative
so again showing the difficulty of
picking up
a particular species as a potential
intermediary host and we also look
uh in the process of helping us to
prioritize
our recommendations and prioritize
studies to be conducted we also
looked at what are the different
possible pathways for this virus
entering the human population back in
2019
and that helped us organize our thoughts
and and prioritize our
recommendations and there we looked at
four
possible pathways for the introduction
of the virus one was
a direct introduction from the host
animal from a reservoir
and that could be a bat or another
animals where the virus had been
initially present directly into the
human population
then we looked at
this scenario together with an
intimately host meaning the virus would
have first jumped
into an animal adapted into that animal
population and then
jumped and adapted to the human
population
and then we also look at the possibility
of
frozen food products or or contaminated
products
being a vehicle for the virus allowing
the virus to
enter the the particular uh
further away and there this uh this
interesting lead
into frozen farmed wild animal products
present and sold in the market in one
market
are very interesting and weren't further
studies
to explore that that hypothesis and the
last one of course was the
the possibility of laboratory
accident or leak and
in doing so we looked at
all the the arguments
for and argument against we had for each
of these hypotheses
of each of these pathways and we try to
stay to
what arguments we have the artifacts we
have
we try to stay away from
suspicions ids theories and so on
because
we couldn't really use that in a
systematic way for all the hypotheses to
help
us moving forward and there we
in that process we then assessed the
likelihood of each of these
possible pathways and organized our
recommendation
towards the ones that were in as
the outcome of our work the most
interesting to
continue with and in particular with
regards to
the current joint group the joint group
of experts between chinese experts and
international experts
where and how this group can best uh
and most in the most useful way
conduct the necessary additional studies
in in better again exploring certain of
these hypotheses and
improving our understanding of the
source of the virus
in closing i'll just say that it has
been an incredible experience
we really uh learned a lot
uh you will see if you dig into the
report it's a huge report
uh can understand the challenge of going
through that in a short period of time
but it's a huge report with a lot a lot
of
new knowledge a lot of data a lot of new
information
and i think a lot of
work will continue to come out out of
these initial studies
and we also of course have to thank
hundreds and hundreds of people who made
this work possible
both uh in the in in the host country in
china facilitating
uh all our work gathering data
generating data
together with us but also a huge
logistical
uh challenge to get us to wuhan and stay
there for months as you know traveling
these days is not easy bringing an
entire team from
outside is not easy so it has been
really challenging uh
time for for for for the whole team to
to get there
do the work and came out again so um on
this
i would like to thank you all and uh
give the flow over to carrick tariq over
to you please
thank you very much peter just uh two
technical uh
things uh first is uh dr banabarak has
used
some slides that those who are on zoom
were able to see but those following us
through broadcasters
all through social media were not able
to see and we may uh
send these uh slides for everyone to
to be able to see them after the press
conference i also understand that uh
for generous round zoom they have missed
the introduction that i made so i'll
just briefly
repeat that the report has been posted
uh some 15 minutes
before the beginning of the press
briefing at the
at the webpage and we have sent the link
to that webpage
uh alongside with the press release uh
to our
media list uh you may contact media
inquiries
uh at www.int if you have not received
any of that just repeat that we have uh
10 scientists
with us and i will read one more time
the names for
journalists uh who have not heard me
uh the first time so professor dr t
fisher professor john watson professor
dr marian coopens professor doctor
dominic dwyer vladimir davkov dr
hunga nguyen professor dr fabian
landertz dr peter dashak dr fargel
and professor dr ken maeda their
affiliation and places they work
normally uh you can find on our website
so
uh after these opening remarks from dr
peter banabarik
we will go to the three co-chairs of
subgroups so
first we will start with dr tara fisher
who was co-leading the group
on epidemiology professor dr
fisher the floor is yours
thank you very much and thanks so much
for
a very strong presentation um
made by the entire team but presented by
our
team lead it's a pleasure to to reach
this day with the final publication of
the report
and um i think peter has already
uh really worded it very well
so from the ippy side um i would just
like to
underscore the main findings
they are our preliminary findings of
course as this is just the very first
step
on a expectedly long
trip to find their region but we have
managed to come
quite far with the joint work and you
have to remember this is based on 28
days
of international travel to wuhan of
which only
two weeks 14 days were working actually
jointly
together uh indeed in the various teams
and in the entire team so from the ep
side we have been reviewing
thousands and thousands of data points
we have reviewed data points of
respiratory surveillance data we have
reviewed data points of mortality data
we have looked at pharmaceutical data
and we have looked specifically and
zoomed in
on the already known early cases from
december 2019 in wuhan
all in all trying to get as much
information
as we could looking for early cases
looking for previous smaller epidemics
that were not yet
identified we have looked really
scrutinized the
respiratory data and so far we have not
been able to document
any substantial transmission of sas
coronavirus
in the month preceding the outbreak in
december
however we cannot exclude that there
have been milder cases
and there might have been smaller
epidemics that that have gone under the
radar
as with our current knowledge of code 19
some of these cases and that's actually
the waste majority
they might only have mild symptoms so
this is
indeed a possibility that we cannot
exclude based on the current findings
and we have made a substantial amount of
recommendations
some of the data we will recommend to
revisit
and re-review jointly and that would be
the next step forwards
and in addition to that some of the very
important
recommendations are also that we will
jointly undertake
a seriality study looking at blood
donors
who are otherwise healthy
people and look for any traces of south
koruna virus antibodies
in these populations in the months
preceding the outbreak
so all in all many important
first preliminary findings many
important
joint recommendations for the next steps
and we welcome the questions you will
have to the work we have today presented
here both in the presentation and in the
report
on the joint ep and the joint
international team
thank you very much
professor fisher now we will go to uh
professor dr marion cookman
who was co-leading a subgroup
on molecular epidemiology
yes thank you tariq um also very briefly
so uh just to emphasize that uh
part of the work in a molecular epi
team has been trying to see what we can
learn from bringing together
virus genomic data
we've all learned in this pandemic how
important genomic
data can be we are seeing that used
every day now
um so we've really done uh
an effort to look at the earliest
available data
bring that together from different
laboratories
and going back to the original data and
and re-analyzing them
to see what are sort of the golden
sequence data from that first episode
and what can we learn
from that and that may seem like a very
simple
endeavor but in reality it is not uh
because
molecular data are generated in
laboratories
and they are released for instance
through the
global database gs8
but then they are not linked with
the patients that they came from so that
was a piece of work that was
needed in order to really see how the
molecular data could help
reconstruct the early phase of
the pandemic in wuhan
and the key conclusion there supported
already the findings from the
epidemiology that
the market in juana has been an
important amplifier event but that
they're also
already at the time of those early cases
was some virus diversity telling us
there was some chains of transmission
missed so we have to dig
uh back a little bit further
um and then there's also this so what
was summarized is all the genomic data
that well we're going to leave that news
conference
uh in geneva there the wh o reporting
back
on its findings regarding the origins of
kovid 19 the director general
of the who saying in the last few
minutes that the who does not believe
the joint wh china probe in wuhan was
extensive enough
further data and studies will be needed
to reach more robust
conclusions the report did conclude a
laboratory leak was the least
likely hypothesis but it does require
further investigation
uh experts believing that the virus was
first transmitted
uh via an animal so we're leaving
that there but we are going to take you
to